ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋อ่ะสวัสดีค่ะน้องอัญ
ตี้สวัสดีครับมีเพียง
ครับผมฟ้าวหาเรียนภาษาไทยกับครูปาร์ตี้
เก๋
ที่อับ Channel ไหนคะอ๋ออ๋อคอม Friends
Circle ไทยนะครับ
ไทยนะคะอัพก็วันนี้วันอะไรครับที่เออวัน
นี้วันพุธชายแล้ววันนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะขออันวันพุธที่ 10 ครับ
วันนี้วันพุธที่ 10 ใช่เดือนอะไรคะค่ะอ่า
ตี้ 5 เดือนนี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับค่ะ
จิกายนปีพตเท่าไหร่คะมีพ.ศ
ที่
564 ครับมี
2564 นะคะได้ครับขอศ.เท่าไหร่คะปีคศ
21/5  2,000  21 นะครับปีขายครับ
สวัสดีคะแล้วตอนนี้ครับเวลา
ตอนนี้ไหมมีตอนนี้เวลา
16:00 น 16:00 นตรงครับ 5  16:00 น
16:00 นนะคะๆครับสี่เหลี่ยมเย็นสบายๆฮ่า
ๆๆใช่เขา 4 โมงเย็นนะคะครับ 4 เย็น
เวลา oku อาทิเอคัพอีก 1 ชั่วโมงคูเอก
ต้องไปทำอาหารไปอ๋ออ๋อไปทำอาหารไม่ใช่
มั้ยครับอ่าอ๋อโอเคไม่ต้องไปทำอาหารเนาะ
อ๋ออ่อน 5 โมงใช่ไหมอีก 1 ชั่วโมงไปทำ
อาหารอาตอน 5:00 นโอเคโอเคครูเอ๋ทำอาหาร
นะคะออกทำอาหารอร่อยไหมครับอร่อยนะอ่า
โอเค
คอย
โอเคอ่าออนไลพ hoi โอเคโอเคนักเรียนอยาก
รู้อร่อยไม่อร่อยมาประเทศไทยเดี๋ยวคุย
เกมมากินอาหารกับครูเอ๋ใช่มั้ยอ่ะว้าวพูด
ถึงทำอาหารกูอันตี้วันนี้ครู Arty มีรูป
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับมีรูปด้วย
ก็ได้มั้ยอ้าอันนี้กินได้ครับอะไรคะ
อันนี้นี่นี่คนไทยเรียก
น้ำตาลถ้าใช่ครับใครเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะ
เรียกน้ำตาลครับทำไมน้ำตาลมี 2 สี
น้ำตาลมี 2 สีครับมีสีน้ำตาล
ครับหน้าแล้วก็มีสีขาวให้สีขาวใช่ครับถ้า
กูเอมีน้ำตาลมาด้วยมีนะมีน้ำตานะเหมือน
กันเลยนี่น้ำตาลอุ้ยหน้ากูเห็นลองลองกิน
น้ำตาสั้นน้ำตาลรสชาติเป็นยังไงครับไม่มี
ช้อนมีช้อนโอเคมีช้อนอี้เอ๋ใช้มือจับช้อน
แล้วก็เอ้อน้ำตาลมีน้ำตาน้องก๋วยตักน้ำ
ตาลโอเคนิดหน่อยนะคะหน่อยครับ
ขอโทษนะคะ 5 กูเอกกินน้ำตาลโอ้วกินน้ำตาล
หวานเป็นยังไงครับอ๋อหวาน
ตัว f สิทธิ์ก่อนนะผู้ Arty ขอปิดก่อน
ครับปิดน้ำตาลนี่เรียกว่าอะไรค่ะควรติ
อาหารนี้เรียกว่าฝาอ่าฝานะคะอ่ะฝาปิดฝา
ขวดข้างบนรึหมุนหน้าหมุน 5 มูลไม่โอเคไม่
6 แล้วเควสปิดแล้วไม่ 6 แล้ว
ว่าน้ำตาลหวานใช่ไหมครับหวาน
ครูเอ๋
ชอบหวานอ๋ออ๋อคุยชอบหวานเหรอครับ 5 ตัว
ที่ไหมคอบหวานนิดอีกนิดหน่อยหายเขาพี่ก็
เลยผอมเนาะ
ตัวผอมใช่มั้ยตัวเล็กน่ะตัวผอมโอเคไม่ชอบ
หวาน
หวาน r  k มีนักเรียนระหานมีอะไรหวานบ้าง
คะอ๋ออ๋อมีมีอ่ามีหวานเยอะเลยมีขนมนี่
ครัวตีมีขนมหวานเนื้อนาค
หวานมาท้ายโดนัทหวานครับ
[เพลง]
มีเค้กไหมมีแค่นี่มีเค้กครับเค้กเค้กก็
หวาน
หวานและไม่น่ะช็อกโกแลตอยู่นี่อยู่ที่
โดนัทช็อกโกแลตอันนี้ให้ครับผมมากลมๆ
กลมๆ
อ่าอันนี้ล่ะครับหรืออันนี้จะใกล้ๆสีแดง
สีส้มช็อกโกแลตไม่ได้ใช่อันนี้หรอครับ
ข้างล่างมีอันนี้ข้างล่างข้างล่างต้อง
โดนัทไอ้ๆโดนัลด์ a  s  i  s  u
อันนี้อ๋อ
ใจครับอันนี้เป็นช็อกโกแลตเอ็มแอนด์เอ็ม
ช็อกโกแลต
หวานครับหวาน
แล้วก็มี j7  Jelly เยลลี่น่าจะรี่ได้
ครับอ่ามี Jelly  Jelly ก็หมูหลาน
หมาใครครับกูเอชอบหวานคู่เอกชอบทุกอย่าง
เลยนะครับชอบ
จ่ายชอบช็อกโกแลต
ถามชอบช็อกโกแลตโอเคชอบ
[เพลง]
ถ้าชอบโดนัทโอเคอ่าเก๋ขอบเค้ก
ว้าวน่ากินหัวตีเห็นแล้วอยากกินด้วย
เหมือนกันอยากกินห่า 8 หวานกินนิดหน่อย
โอเคเนาะตายเขากินนิดหน่อยอยากกินเยอะไม่
ดีอ่ะกินนิดหน่อยสายหาดนะคะทานอ่ะก็มีรส
ชาติหวานเนาะหนูครับ
มีมิมีมิมีรสชาติอื่นอีกไหมคะอามีรสชาติ
อื่นครับ R ครัวตี้มีรสชาติ
อ้าวเปรี้ยวครับคืออะไรคะอันนี้คือมะนาว
ชายครับอากูเอรู้จักมะนาวนี่มะนาว
เอก
กูเอ๋กินฮะ
โอเคไม่มีมีด Way บีบเลยนะคะกินนิดเดียว
เธอฮ่าๆฮึ
เป็นยังไงเขาเป็นยังไง
อ๋ออ๋อครูเอกเปรี้ยวหรอไม่ได้หวานใช่ไหม
ไม่หวานเปรี้ยว
[เพลง]
มะนาวเปรี้ยวมะนาวมีรสเปรี้ยวเออเด็กกับ
ครูเอ๋เหมือนกัน
เปรี้ยวเหมือนกันที่ห้องเหมือนกันเด็ก
เค้ากินมะนาวคู่เอกก็กินมะนาวเปรี้ยวฮ่าๆ
ๆเอกก็ชอบนะชอบมะนาว
อันนี้ก็น้ำมะนาว
คุณหมอมีน้ำมะนาวด้วยแต่ว่าใส่ใส่ใส่น้ำ
ตาลด้วยก็เลยไม่ใส่น้ำตาลก็จะเปรี้ยวน้อย
ค่ะหวานเยอะ
กินหลอดนะคะน้องคู่เอกก็ดูดอ๋ออ๋อดูดน้ำ
มะนาวเอเปรี้ยว
ๆเดี๋ยวนะนักเรียนวิเคราะห์เปรี้ยวไม่นะ
คะตีห้อเปรียวออกแล้วต่อเปรี้ยวแต่
กลัวติไม่กินเปรี้ยวจากมะนาวครัวตี้กิน
เปรี้ยวจากผลไม้จากอะไรคะจากผลไม้นี่มี
ผลไม้เปรี้ยวอะไรคะอ่านี่ครับ
เข้ามาให้มาอ่ามีผู้ชี้ฟ้ากลับมาอีกแล้ว
นี่ครับโอ้ว
เอออะไรผลไม้อ่ะมะม่วงครับอยากหน้ามะม่วง
เล็กๆไหมใต้ครับมะม่วงดิบอาอาเหยากาเล็ก
มิเยา
เที่ยวได้ครับกลัวตี้ชอบชอบมะม่วงเปรี้ยว
ค่ะคนไทยเรียกมะม่วงเบานะตัวนี้ค่ะ
ช่อม่วงเบาใช่ไหมครับแต่มะม่วงเปล่าไม่
เกี่ยวเลยนกเล็กลูกใหญ่ๆมะม่วงเลยแล้วก็
ปรี่
อ่ามะม่วงเบาอ๋ออ๋อมะม่วงเบาแทงเล็กแล้ว
ก็ปีเบี้ยวมากกว่าติชอบมากชอบมากๆ
เนื้อหาอ้าวกูเอ๋โอ๋โอเคกูเอ๋ดาว
ชอบกินมะนาวแล้วก็เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยว
มีผลไม้มีผลไม้อื่นทิเปรี้ยวอีกนะคะมี
อะไรคะเออมีอะไรนี่ครับ
นี่ถ้ากูอตตี้นี่คนไทยเรียบมะยมมะยมไม่
ยอมซ้ายครับไม่ยมมีรสเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวมาก
เปรี้ยวใส่เขาฮ่าๆเปรี้ยว
เปรี้ยว
ฮ่าๆเปรี้ยวมากเลยครับพี่
ยอมเหรอคะกล้วยติดห้องไม่ยมนิดหน่อยนิด
หน่อยชอบมะม่วงมากกว่าง่วงมากดีกว่าไอ
ครับวันนี้ตอนนี้กูเห็นน้ำลายไหลแล้วเอ๋
อยากกินอยากกินมะยมอย่าครับเวลาเปรี้ยว
น้ำลายจะออก
ๆ
อร่อยค่ะนักเรียนมะยมอร่อยตี้คิด
ว่ากูเอ๋อยากกินมะยมอยากกินไข่อัดกินอ่า
หน้าไม่มีที่บ้านกูเอไม่มีมะยงขอบ้านครัว
ตี้เกาะไม่มีมะยม
ตอนไหนออกมะยมอยากกินนะคะอ่ะนี่ผลไม้ไหม
เลยไม่มีแล้วอ่าไม่มีแล้วผัวตี้มีแค่มะยม
แล้วก็มะม่วงครับวันนี้แล้วก็อาบ
น้ำตาลเนี่ยมีรสหวานเสร็จแล้ว
ใช่ครับ
และมีรสเปรี้ยวเสร็จแล้วมะนาวเปรี้ยว
มีรสอื่นไหมคะถ้ามีรถตื่นอีกครับอ้ามีรถ
นี้นี่ที่
นี่คือ
พริกทัพหน้าพลีคอานี่พลิก
มีพริกไหมมีปิค
โคโยตี้เอาปิดเนี้ย
ลายมากเลยนะเขาครูเอ๋ยังกินอีกไหมเข้ามี
พริกสีแดงกับคลิกสีเขียวปาร์ตี้มีพริกสี
แดง
มิกสีเขียวสีอะไรอีกครับมีซิเกือบจะแดง
ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเป็นสีน้ำตาล
ชายขอคุยกะมีพริกสามสีครัวตี้มีมีสีแดง
คู๋มีสีเขียวสีน้ำตาลแล้วก็มีสีแดงว่า
ว้าววันตีขาหารถอะไรค่ะ
pic รสเผ็ดครับรถ 7 เส้นไหมคะแอบได้ครับ
เหตุเดี๋ยวกู rgb จะให้ครูเอกกินรสไหนคะ
จริงสีไหนไม่ต้องกินค่ะ
กินได้ให้หมอเอ๋อยากกินสีอะไรครับจะเขียว
ดีกว่าอย่างนี้เขียวโอเค
อ่าโอเคอ่ะอร่อยเด็กกินเยอะๆค่ะอ้ากินนิด
หน่อยนิดหน่อยอ่ะอยากกินเยอะนักเรียนพริก
นะคะเล็กเผ็ดมากๆ
ใหญ่ผิดเล็กหน่อยอ๋ออ๋อเหรอครับแต่
อันเนี้ยพริกเล็ก
เล็กเผ็ดมากฮ่าๆ
มีมีเกลืออ๋อมีเกลือด้วยเกลือกับมะนาว
เว็บเพจก็กินน้ำตาลได้น้ำตาลหวานพริก
เห็ด
เวียนคู๋กัด 5 คันเลยครับนักเรียน
x กัดไม่กัดให้นักเรียนช่วยแล้วช่วยเสีย
สู้ๆ
จัด 5  9 จัดนะจัดนะ
อ้าเป็นยังไงครับ
น้ำเหตุใช่ไหมครับอ่า
ดี
กว่าติกูอีกขอ
รถจะไปเลยอะไรรู้ไหมโอเคอันนี้ร้อนต่อไป
เดี๋ยวค่อยย้อนกลับ
ขอกินก่อน
คู๋กินอะไรครับ
อ๋อเกมเกลือเธอก็อยากกินเกลือเกลือๆ
เดี๋ยวกลัวตีเปิดรูปเกลือให้นักเรียนดู
นี่ครับกูเอกกินเกลือค่ะเรือ
โอเคล่ะ
เวลาเผ็ดนะคะนักเรียนแท็กครับกินพริกแล้ว
ก็เผ็ดกินเกลือเผ็ดจะน้อยลงน้อยลงน้อยลง
อ๋อ
และก็เค็มโอเคแต่เผ็ดยังมีอยู่อ่ะกูอัด
ครับ
จริงๆนะคะถ้า 5 เทคนิคอย่างเงี้ยกลับแล้ว
ไม่เผ็ดน่ะ
เอ๊ะไอ้เพศโอเค
โอเคค่ะมีอาหารเห็ดไหมกูอติ
อาหารเผ็ดใช่ไหมครับครัวซิมีอาหารเพจครับ
นี่เพจนี้ครับหานี่ผัดพริกปลา
หน้านี่ปลาแล้วก็มีพริกมีพริกเยอะเลยเป็น
ผัดพริกปลา
คู่เอกชอบชอบกินเผ็ดไหมครับครูเอกชอบกิน
อ้าครัวตี้ก็ชอบอยากกินเผ็ด
เผ็ดมากๆอ่ะฮ่าๆกินเก็บมากด้วยใช่ไหมครับ
อ่ะแต่ไม่กินพริกอย่างนี้นะคะอาหารแล้ว
พ่อใช่ครับหน้าต้องใส่ลงไปในอาหาร
อายครับ
เดี๋ยวนะครับ
พริกโดนตา
พีคโดนตาว้าว
[เพลง]
โอเคค่ะเผ็ดที่นี่ผิดที่ด้วยค่ะนักเรียน
ค่ะโอ้เผ็ดหน้าเผ็ดเยอะเลยอันนี้เป็น
อาหารเผ็ดนะคะอะมีเมื่อกี้อะไรคาดอะไรนะ
เค็มใช่ไหมคะ
อ้ารสชาติเค็มน่ะกลับไปที่รสชาติเค็มอ่า
นี่เกลือนี่เอ๋มือถือเปลืองมีรสเค็มใช่
ครับใช่
คู๋ไม่ชอบกินเค็ม
อ๋ออ๋อกลัวนี่ก็ไม่ชอบกินเค็มๆครับกูเอ
ชอบคู่เอกชอบรสเปรี้ยว
เปรี้ยวจากมะนาวนะฮะรอบหวานน้ำตาล
ขวาน
ชอบคลิปรสเผ็ดสาขาแรกเกลือแล้วก็เค็มเก๋
ไม่ชอบอ๋อ
ๆมันเค็มไหมคะกลัวตี้ไม่ชอบเค็มกลัวตี้
ชอบเปรี้ยวๆครับอ่ะเปรี้ยวครูอาร์ทตี้คะ
มะนาวเนี่ยเปรี้ยว
เค็ม
รวมกันครู Arty ชอบไหมคะเอ่ออ๋ออ๋อกลัว
ตี้ชอบครับถ้ารวมมะนาวกับเกลือรวมกัน
เปรี้ยวและเค็มรวมกันชอบคำอ๋อพ่อ
เค็มไม่ชอบไม่ชอบเข้มอย่างเดียวไม่ชอบจะ
ทำมะนาวเปรี้ยวครับชอบนะคะให้ครับเออ
[เพลง]
ครูอาร์ทตี้แล้วมีอาหาร
ที่
เดี๋ยวกู Arty ครับยังไม่อาหารเค็มเค็ม
kuai มีอันนี้ก็มีอะไรอีกครับดอกตัวตีก็
มีอ้าอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับน้ำปลาไส้ครับเออ
กินนะ
ปลาเค็มใช่ไหมครับเกมอ่า
และเพื่อเค็มเกลือเกลือเค็มเค็ม
เกลือมีรสเค็มๆครับน้ำปลามีรสเค็ม
ไปค่ะข้าวมีรสเปรี้ยวนะคะต้องน้ำตาลมีรถ
อะไรคะ 5 น้ำตาลมีรสหวานครับหวานนะคะออย
ก็มีเนาะปลาเค็มนะคะอาหาและเมี่ยงอื่น
เค็มอีกไหมคะผัวตี้โคโยตี้มีอาหารเค็มมา
ทานแฮมอะไรครับหน้านี้ครับ
ว้าวมี
อะไรเรียบปลาปลาเค็ม
[เพลง]
ปลาเค็ม
ไม่ชอบเค็มแต่คู่น่ารักปลาเข็ม
นักเรียนจบขายคู่เหตุไม่ชอบเค็มแถบชอบปลา
เค็มๆ
ก็กูเอกก็จะเอาน้ำตาลน้ำตาล
ๆ
อ้าวเอาพริกใส่อ๋อนี่เอาพริกนี่พริกอยู่
ตรงนี้ถ้าเราก็เอามะนาวมีสไตล์ฮ้อ
รวมกันรวมพริกรวมมาร Now รวมปลาเค็มรวม
กันใช่ไหมครับไม่กิน
ปลาเค็มแล้วก็กินแค่อ๋อ
โอเคเกมมากๆสวัสดีก็ชอบกินรวมกันน่ะกิน
ปลาเค็มมะนาวแล้วก็พริก
ไม่มีอะไรสิคำผู้ชมภูติชมพูเป็นหัวหอม
ครับหอมแดงหอมใช่ครับหัวหอมแดงครับ
หิวครู Arty คะแล้วมีอะไรที่มีรสเค็ม
เรือหรือนามิเกลือล้างน้ำปลาใช้ครับรส
เค็มนะคะครับก็รสหวานมีน้ำตาลตายแล้วก็มี
รสเปรี้ยวจากมะนาว
ครับเผ็ดจากพริก
ครับ
อาหารอะไรคะที่เค็มเผ็ดเปรี้ยวหวานหมอ
โอ๊ตมีเข็มเพชรเปรี้ยวหวานอ้ามีอาหารอะไร
ใช่ไหมครับมีครัวตี้มีอาหารที่มีเค็มที่ 7
เปรี้ยวหวานนี่ครับมิๆครับฮ่าๆๆอะไรคะ
นั่นไทยเรียกต้มยำต้มยำกุ้งหน้าต้มยำกุ้ง
มีพริกนี่พริกเผ็ด 5 แล้วก็มีอ่า
เข็ดน้ำซุปตรงนี้อ้ามีมะนาวมีน้ำปลานะ
ครับอ่าแล้วก็มีน้ำตาลอยู่ในต้มยำกุ้งๆ
เลยนะมีตรงนี้ได้มีครบเลย
หือนี่ค่ะใส่ด้วยใส่ลงไปในต้มยำกุ้งคู่
เอ๋
ชอบต้มยำกุ้งไหมครับครูเอ๋ชอบกินต้มยำ
กุ้งค่ะครู Arty แอปกินไม่ได้
เพราะว่าครูเอกกินโป้ขาทันอ๋ออ๋อ
กินแล้วคลันขอกินต้มยำกุ้งคันถ้ากินต้มยำ
ไก่นะจ๊ะ
โอเคได้ๆเอาเป็นต้มยำต้มยำไก่อ่ะ
แต่นักเรียนอ่ะชอบต้มยำกุ้งใช่ไหมคะต้มยำ
กุ้งก็จะมีรสเค็ม
ใช่เปรียวอ้าหวานอาครับร้อนเผ็ดใช่ไหมคะ
มีหน้าถ้ามีอะไรคะ
มะนาวมะนาว
น้ำตา
ตาลพริกตาได้ครับอ่าร่วมกันนะคะอ้ารวมกัน
ตัวตี้มีอาหารที่มีรสรวมกันอีกเมื่อ
มีวิธีเที่ยวเพจกว่าวายได้ครับแก้มมาอะไร
ค่ะอ่านี่ครับ
ว้าว
ตำส้มตำชัยครับหน้านี่ส้มตำอยู่แล้วเหรอ
บอกว่าจะไปทำอาหารตอนห้าโมงแต่ตอนนี้หิว
แล้ว
อ้า
ส้มตำ
ครับชอบส้มตำเพราะว่าเราชอบที่มะนาวเนาะ
มะนาวทรายครับมีมะนาว
มีพริกไปคะปิ๊กมีครับมีพลีสนี่มีปลีกมี
น้ำปลาเนาะน้ำปลาใช่ครับก็มีน้ำตาลน้ำตาล
ถูกต้องมีน้ำตาลร้านต้มยำก็เลยจะเรี้ยว 5
เผ็ดเห็ดด้วยน้าชายขับเห็ดเค็มทะปาใส่น้ำ
ปลาเค็มแล้วก็อะไรคะ
ใส่น้ำตาลหวานๆครับและถ้าหวาน
ต่ำมีผสมฮะอ้า
อะไรครับชอบใช่ไหมกูเอชอบส้มตำมาก
มากกลัวนี่ก็ชอบชอบมากๆให้กู Arty คะวัน
นี้นักเรียนได้ฟังเนาะรสชาตินะคะรสชาติ
อาหารนะคะอัพเรามาดูใหม่เนาะอ่าอ่ะโอเค
ถามนะคะอันแรกมีอะไรนะคะอันแรกน้ำตาลครับ
น้ำตาลมีรสชาติยังไงคะอ้าพี่ตาลมีรสหวาน
ครับน้ำตาลมีรสหวานราคาให้ต่อไปอันนี้
อะไรคะครู Arty อ้าอันนี้มะนาวครับมะนาว
มีรถอะไรคะอ้ามะนาวมีรสเปรี้ยวมะนาวมีรส
เปรี้ยวนะคะต่อไปอะไรคะผู้อ่านตี้ขอก็
พริกครับอ่ะคลิกมีรถอะไรคะอ้าอะพริกมีรส
เผ็ดอันนี้รสเผ็ดนาเห็ดชายครับกลับไปอะไร
คะภู Arty อ๋ออ่อนนี้น้ำปลาน้ำปลาอนาคา
น้ำปลาสด Sorry สิบ
เอกก็ได้น้ำตาแล้วหาอะไรคะอ้าแล้วก็เกลือ
ครับจ้าน้ำปลากับเกลือมีรสอะไรเนื้อหามี
รสเค็มอ่ะน้ำปลากับเกลือมีรสเค็มราคาครับ
น้ำตากับเกลือมีรสเค็มงั้นวันนี้นักเรียน
ก็รู้จักรสหวานรสเปรี้ยวรสเผ็ดแล้วหาใช้
ครับเค็ม
เสร็จแล้วต้องไปทำอาหารอ๋อพี่ก็ต้องไปกิน
อ่า
ตัวตีก็ไปกินข้าวใช่ครับข้าวกินข้าวนะคะ
ครูเอ๋ชอบชอบอาหารเค็ม
เผ็ดเปรี้ยวหวานด้วยกันหน้ารายการอะตีล่ะ
คะหัวตี้ก็ชอบชอบเค็มเผ็ดเปรี้ยวหวานรวม
กันรวมไปด้วยนักเรียนราคะชอบไหมชอบ
เปรี้ยวเผ็ดเค็มหวานรวม
หรือว่าแยก
ระอา
ครูอันที่อยากรู้ไหมอยากรู้มั้ยเวลาแกรู้
กวนพี่อยากรู้ๆครูเองก็อยากรู้นักเรียน
ชอบอาหาร 4 รถรวมกันหรือแยกกันนะคะครับ
ให้นักเรียนบอกบอกกลัวตี้บอกครูเอ๋ใน
คอมเม้นเออคีย์ในคอมเม้นนะครับครับวันนี้
หมดเวลาหรือยังคะขออาตี้อาหมดเวลาแล้ว
ครับเดี๋ยวลาเรา่
ได้ครับ OS อ่าท่าทรายครับกลัวตีก็บ๊าย
บายไปก่อนเหมือนกันนะเตือนพรุ่งนี้น่ะ
สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอัตตีนครับ
นักเรียนวัดผมเรียนบ๊ายบายบ๊ายลา
กดไลค์กดแชร์กดสักอ้าวอันได้
ที่ช่องคอมเพรน Small ไทยด้วยครับ
ครับผมบ๊ายบายน